des conteneurs de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de doses de vaccins contre
ebola
tout fraîchement arrivé en guinée est
fournie par l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
ce mardi presque immédiatement après
l'arrivée des onze mille doses de
vaccins dans le pays la campagne de
vaccination contre le virus a été lancée
dans la préfecture de n'zérékoré dans le
sud ouest du pays
à l'épicentre de la résurgence de
l'épidémie qui frappe à nouveau le pays
les premières deux ont été inoculés aux
résidents qui ont été en contact avec
des malades ainsi qu'au personnel
soignant de la réduction heureux de se
voir enfin protégés par cette campagne
vaccinale
je suis et c'est une joie pour moi que
la population du week-end en matinée et
je suis fier que la population il y a
une semaine l'om est déclarée le début
officiel de l'épidémie de fièvre
hémorragique
après que les autorités locales ont
recensé de nombreux cas avec symptômes
de saignements diarrhées et vomissements
selon un décompte officiel
il y aurait déjà huit morts la dernière
flambée du virus ebola en afrique de
l'ouest avaient eu lieu entre 2013 et
2016 et avait fait dans la région plus
de onze mille trois cents morts dont
plus de 500 professionnels de santé mais
cette fois-ci conakry et l' oms estime
mieux armé qu'il ya cinq ans grâce à
l'expérience précédente et bien sûr
grâce aux progrès de la vaccination avec
le sérum efficace contre la souche zaïre
du virus celle qui semblerait être
présente en guinée les autorités sont
confiantes quant à l'évolution de
l'épidémie à disposition
à travers le programme des étudiants de
l' oms serons en mesure de nous aider à
stopper la propagation de la maladie qui
sont destinés essentiellement au cercle
de contacts et des cas que nous
connaissons mais aussi un cercle à un
deuxième cercle éventuellement pour nous
assurer d'interrompre la chaîne de
transmission les ans est bonne cette
situation et si aujourd'hui nous avons
procédé au lancement de la vaccination
ça veut dire que dans un bref délai moi
j'ai dit j'ai midi dans six semaines
plus tard j'arrive à cette épidémie
les nations unies ont annoncé une
première allocation de quelques 15
millions de dollars destinés à la
riposte contre l'épidémie de virus ebola
en république démocratique du congo et
en guinée après la région de n'zérékoré
ce sont tous les sites du pays
nécessitant la protection des personnes
en contact avec les malades qui seront
ciblés afin d'enrayer la propagation de
cette nouvelle épidémie qui préoccupe
non seulement la guinée mais aussi les
pays voisins